REVIEW AT WHICH POINT CITIZENS
AND CITY OFFICIALS CAN ALSO
COMMENT.
AS WE TOLD YOU EARLIER PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAS SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER IMPOSING STIFF PENALTIES
FOR ASSAULTS IN U.S. MONUMENT
SPURRED THE DIRECTOR OF THE FBI
SAYS FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
WILL NOT TOLERATE RIOTING AND
DESTRUCTION OF THOSE MONUMENTS.
CHRISTOPHER RAY TELLING FOX NEWS
HUNDREDS OF INDIVIDUALS ARE
BEING INVESTIGATED FOR WHAT HE
CALLS VIOLENT EXTREMIST AGENDAS.
>> AS MONUMENTS FALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, FBI AGENTS ARE WATCHING
IT IN REAL TIME FROM THIS ROOM.
>> THE FBI RECOGNIZES THE RIGHTS
OF AMERICAN CITIZENS TO EXERCISE
THEIR FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS,
WHEN IT CROSSES INTO ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY, IT IS SOMETHING WE
HAVE TO ADDRESS.
>> WE WERE GRANTED EXCLUSIVE
ACCESS TO THE STRATEGIC
INFORMATION AND OPERATIONS UNDER
WHERE OFFICIALS ARE WATCHING
TRENDS IN VANDALISM, RESPONDING
TO THOSE TRENDS, AND
SYNTHESIZING ANY COLLECTED
INTELLIGENCE TO FIND THAT NEXT
HOTSPOTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
>> WE EXPECTED GOING INTO FLEX
COUPLE OF WEEKS THAT INDIVIDUALS
INCLUDE EXTREMIST WOULD TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF AMERICANS
EXERCISING THEIR RIGHT TO
PEACEFULLY PROTEST AND WHAT I
WOULD CALL HIJACK THAT FOR THEIR
OWN PERSONAL OPPORTUNISTIC ACTS
OF COMMITTING CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
OR A VIOLENT SPREAD.
>> FROM PORTLAND OREGON TO
BOSTON, MASSACHUSETTS UNREST
BLANKETS DOZENS OF CITIES.
IN SOME CASES, CITY OFFICIALS
REMOVED STATUES, BUT OTHER TIMES
, CROWDS COOK TOOK CONTROL
PULLING DOWN STATUES LIKE THIS
ONE OF CONFEDERATE GENERAL
ALBERT PIKE BEFORE SETTING IT ON
FIRE.
>> AT THE VIOLENCE AND
DESTRUCTION OF PROPERTY THAT WE
HAVE BEEN SEEING IN CERTAIN
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY AS ILLEGAL.
IT NEEDS TO STOP NOW.
>> FBI DIRECTOR CHRISTOPHER RAY
TELLS FOX NEWS HIS JOB AS TO
STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE.
>> EQUAL JUSTICE IS ESSENTIAL,
BUT VIOLENCE AND DESTRUCTION OF
PROPERTY IS NOT THE WAY TO
ENSURE ITS.
>> AGENTS IN THIS ROOM ARE
WATCHING SOCIAL MEDIA CHATTER
AND OTHER COMMUNICATIONS TO
UNCOVER ANY POTENTIAL TERRORISM
NETWORK HOPING TO CASH IN ON THE
UNREST.
>> WHAT I WOULD ASK FOR THE
THOSE WHO WATCH THIS IS WE NEED
YOUR HELP, WE NEED INFORMATION
THAT YOU SEE.
>> AS TIME TICKS CLOSER TO THE
NOVEMBER ELECTION, FBI OFFICIALS
EXPECT TO SEE MORE OF THIS